all right Alexis big return to reality
TV why now why was this the show to come
back to TV for well I feel like I was at
a really big low when I did decide to
take this task on because I had just
moved out of my home and bought a new
home with my children
a month before but I thought if one
relationship failed with my marriage
then why not fix everything that I can
with my mom and build my family up and
and work on other parts of my life and
he never liked me as a kid this show
helped how you hoped it would help did
you walk away feeling like things were
repaired it actually helped more than I
thought it would I mean to an extent
that let I thought my mom and I had one
issue and then once we did the show I
was like okay actually we fixed like
three things so yeah I I feel much
better my mom and I are way closer than
we've ever been nice and positive and a
little date night tonight
how long has this been going on what's
the story behind this relationship I I
was not dating him when I was filming
you got to better yourself when you fall
into this relationship which I just saw
you on housewives saying you didn't know
a love could exist like this I still
haven't had an argument with them like
we we just don't fight like this is the
kind of love that I thought only existed
in fairy tales I really didn't think it
was true
we definitely have a special love in it
you know see see it in each other's
faces every day just in our smiles and
laughs and and giggles and obviously
like the interactions with the children
and all that because we've got a pretty
big crew right now so we cherish our
time together is a little Brady Bunch
situation happening in Orange County we
got we got them all we got six
- what's your ID has to step up to other
stepchildren so 2 2 2 8 16 17 so we have
like seven total run a decade we run a
decade there so I know eight months so
pretty new
this feels like a good thing you guys
both look happy
do you see marriage again in your future
well I know it seems new to everyone
else but we feel like we've already
lived like a lifetime because of
everything we've been through all the
crap we've gone through in the last few
months but um I said no I would not
marry again when I was dating and then I
met him and he changed my world yeah
changed it for sure your say that what
does that make you feel pretty sticky
right now but we're just taking it a day
at a time and obviously just really
enjoying ourselves and everything we do
together so if I were to go spend some
time up in San Francisco the Baria this
weekend and get out and have some fun
two crazy kids in love right here I
don't know if your question he gave me
an answer to a question that you and Jim
I think it shocked housewives viewers
when you two separated because it had
been a minute since we had seen you on
TV what's the status of your
relationship today are we co-parenting
yes it was definitely rocky at first
we've had we've definitely had I mean
going through any divorce I think
there's the time when you it's rocky for
a while and Jim and I are now at a place
where we're good friends and we are
understanding how to co-parent and what
we're where our places are and and yeah
so we're good we're friends which is all
we can ask for because we weren't
friends for a while all right sorry back
in housewives this week did that give
you the itch to come back full-time want
to dive back into that crazy group of
ladies I love my time that I had on
housewives that grew me a lot it taught
me a lot I think that I have turned that
chapter I will do another cameo I just
don't want to I just think it's that
time that's gone last question there's
also a rumor that you're maybe on below
deck this season can you confirm that
I don't know if I'm allowed to think you
just take Alexis I think you just did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]